you are watching a clip from the john
perry channel
genetics and evolution
the our ephemera like the top of the
femur where it hits or inserts into the
hip
it has all these struts
that are optimized for our type of
walking
and it distributes the the pressure well
from you know hitting into the hip and
also back
into the femur so you know so you don't
snap off your uh femoral head which is a
really bad injury
so it's it's a yeah so it's a good way
to distribute that so we have all these
struts too and they've shown that yeah
okay the struts and runners look
different than the struts and you know
your average joe that just maybe walks
to work
um so we look different on the inside
depending on what we're doing and those
definitely remodel over our lifetime so
that's so neat
when we're studying paleontology
how much can
an animal's activity during its life
change its skeleton this is a question
of phenotypic plasticity so you said
that using your muscles changes your
skeleton
weight lifters have slightly different
skeletons than non-weight lifters we
know that in chimpanzees and in gorillas
the change can be extreme like in the
skull when male gorillas go through
puberty they grow this giant crest on
the top of their head and that crest is
not coated for directly in their genes
that crest is a result of genes that
allow bone to grow when muscles tug
on that thin little bit of tissue that's
on the outside of a bone so
i guess you could say that the genes are
coding for that crest but not directly
how much phenotypic plasticity could
there be in an animal skeleton as a
result of genes that do this sort of
thing i mean is it possible for us to
think that we're looking at two
different species when actually we're
just looking at the same species that
lived in very different conditions
so it changed throughout its lifetime
that's that's a really good question
it's almost like a nature versus nurture
situation right
um so i think of it kind of like
we have a set stencil we have a set
structure we have a set plan
there is a certain amount of wiggle room
in certain directions
but it's not so crazy
that you really
if you know the biology of the animal
well
it's it's quite hard to to really think
that once but species is is different
from another that being said
with paleontology a lot of the times we
don't know the biology that well right
sometimes we only have one specimen of
this one animal
and
two three four five years later we find
another specimen that looks similar but
not quite
and and it's difficult it's very
difficult to relax you know where do you
set the line where yeah how much
difference equals a different species
versus
not
and
and
in reality in some ways we're probably
overestimating species because we don't
know um ontogeny we don't know their
growth series very well
and in
other ways we're probably
underestimating um
diversity of species because if you look
at like modern animals and lizards a lot
of them
are completely different species you
know their outside is different their
behavior is different they live in
different niches especially i like the
example of anoles because
in one tree you have the branch animals
you have the ones that live near the
trunk you have the ones that live at the
canopy and they're making all these
different niches across one tree they
all look different they all
behave differently but their skulls are
so similar
so similar and
but they're different species like we
know they're different species we know
they're different species because we
have genetics and we have the external
looks and the behavior and all these
other factors that you don't get
with fossils yeah right and also
when you look at their so when you look
at their skeletons they're they're very
similar but we also have a full skeleton
for them now cut that skeleton into
maybe less than 20 of it put it in a
rock tumbler and tell me if you can
still figure out if it's a different
species or not right that's the
challenge that paleontologists have
so
that's good
well that's it for this clip but don't
worry i post clips regularly and every
thursday i post completely fresh content
make sure you're subscribed
liking and commenting is also welcome